on Thursday in an apparent attempt to
demonstrate that voters in the United
States and Germany couldn't be the only
ones to embrace reactionary
unpredictability the voters of the
United Kingdom dealt the Conservative
Party a stunning blow elevating the far
left labor party led by a known chumps
guest moon named Jeremy Corbyn to the
brink of power the Conservatives led by
Teresa maid will still retain leadership
thanks to a coalition government but
they were expected to walk away with the
election and labour was supposed to be
in disarray
instead the Conservatives are on the
verge of chaos and labour is united
under a terrorist's supporting
anti-semite with a gut-level hatred of
Western civilization
well done Brits Josh crash our of
National Journal makes an even more
important point though the youth vote in
Britain went overwhelmingly for Corvette
quote Corbin surprisingly competitive
showing was fueled by young voters who
rallied behind labour by a whopping 34
point margin 63 to 29
according to British exit polling for
all the fears of creeping nationalism
it's the growing discontent of the
Millennial vote that's been a consistent
theme in recent Western elections many
young voters are rejecting capitalism
entirely attracted to rhetoric promising
free tuition and a generous social
safety net at a time when many are
struggling to make ends meet numerous
studies also show younger voters are
much more skeptical toward the value of
democracies and their elders crash our
right we point out that 27% of young
French voters felt for an actual
communist jean-luc mélenchon in the
United States Democratic Socialist
Bernie Sanders drew quote more than a
more under 30 voters than Clinton and
Trump combined crash our is right to
note that the reactionary left is
responding to the reactionary right the
young voters who resonated Corbin Milan
Sean and Sanders were responding in part
to brexit lepen and Trump and there's
nothing new about young people embracing
radical politics the 60s and 70s were
full of such elections see George
McGovern and the 1930s were full of
radical political movements worldwide
supported by youngsters each generation
has its own brand of radicalism and
given the success of the post world post
Cold War neoliberal consensus the
rebellion was bound to come in the form
of fire left redistribution ISM Clinton
and Bush and Blair and Chirac were all
of the same general mind on capitalism
young people have reacted to that
background commentators are trying to
find economic rationale for the blowback
but there is something else though
on we live in a unique time in human
history war between major powers is
almost inconceivable and despite
economic worries the vast majority of
people are employed the American
unemployment rate is currently four
point seven percent the Brits four point
eight percent the French unemployment
rate is nine point six percent where
it's been hovering since the economic
crash of 2008 yes terrorism is a threat
as is multiculturalism but the farm less
is in pledging to do anything about any
of those things No what we have here is
an entire generation of Westerners
brought up to believe that prosperity
and freedom are the norm and given a
background noise and at the next mission
for which they should fight is
redistribution ISM income inequality is
next Rubicon it's across and income
inequality Springs from the same origins
as racism and sexism and bigotry Western
civilization this perspective is not
coming from disillusionment its
springing from an existential
meaninglessness taught by two
generations and parents who abandon
traditional values in favor of
secularism and are now surprised to find
their secular kids and grandkids
embracing transformative Marxism as a
way to animate their lives people want
meaning economics does not provide
meaning what causes do Bernie appears to
have a cause so does Corbin so didn't
the law shown as economists as
economists Daniel Yergin and Josef
Stanislaus and way back in 1998 when it
appeared the global capitalist consensus
was unshakable quote a system that takes
the pursuit of self-interest and profit
as its guiding light does not
necessarily satisfy the yearning in the
human soul for belief and some higher
meaning beyond materialism few people
would die with the words free markets on
their lips the West has failed to teach
its children meaning the children found
their own meaning in Marxism and so we
appear ready to reimburse the horrors of
the past unless we get to work right now
teaching young Westerners that they are
part of a fight for liberty and freedom
and responsibility rather than for
transformative or crushing
redistribution ism i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
all righty we are going to get into
everything Cobie related we're also
going to talk more about the UK election
which really is quite stunning for
Teresa may the worst political
miscalculation in the modern era
so-called snap elections and then she
ended up almost being thrown out of
office which is just an amazing thing we
also have the mailbag today yes if you
want to be part of the live mailbag
you're going to have to go over to Dan
Lee Weyer calm right now and subscribe
we'll dedicate some real time to the
mailbag today but first I want to say
thanks to our sponsors over at Birch
gold so right now we're living in times
of uncertainty I mean if that British
election should be nothing else it
showed that the global markets are
contingent on some sort of steadiness in
the West and that studying it is not
exactly there right now there's a lot of
unpredictability plus our enemies are on
the move China's on the move Russia's on
the move the markets themselves could be
overvalued there as our report today
said that the the investor famous
investor came out and said that he was
expecting an economic crash any time now
this is just one reason why you should
hedge some of your bets with gold you
should have some gold in your portfolio
should have some precious metals in your
portfolio right now over the last five
months the fact is that the the gold
prices have increased every month for
the first five months in 2017 in 2017
gold is up 13% thus far that is a
reflection of consumer anxiety of
investor anxiety of Apple markets and I
don't think that that anxiety is totally
misplaced right now you can get some
precious metal and you can switch your I
your IRA or eligible 401k into an IRA
backed by physical gold and silver by
calling my friends at Birch gold group
they have a long-standing track record
of continued success they have thousands
of satisfied clients five-star reviews a
plus rating with a Better Business
Bureau right now contact vertical for a
free information can unphysical precious
metals they have a comprehensive 16 page
get revealing how gold and silver can
protect your savings and how you can
legally move again that IRA or 401k out
of stocks and bonds into a precious
metals IRA with this much uncertainty
should certainly have some investment in
precious metals I do birchgold.com slash
pen that's Bert's cool calm slash then
use that slash pens they know that we
sent you and not only we get that 16
page free comprehensive kit and make
sure you ask all your questions but
they'll also know that we sent you and
they'll be more likely to advertise with
in the future and we can bring the show
to you free of charge as you listen okay
so lots happening in the news obviously
lots of fallout from the James Comey
hearing so after having a chance to
reflect there are a bunch of headlines
that coming out of the James Comey
hearing and I want to play I think the
three key clips we have a little mashup
here of the key clips from the Comey
hearing first of all here are the
headlines from quotes were about
straight first of all Comey said openly
the President Trump and his staff did
not ask did not ask for killing of the
Russia investigation this destroys the
Democrat narrative remember as I said
yesterday the entire Democratic
narrative since Hillary walked the
election was that Hillary loss because
Donald Trump worked with Vladimir Putin
to corrupt the election and in doing so
he then had to fire James Comey because
Comey was this close to finding out
about it
that was their narrative that was
completely debunked Comey said that
yesterday also in other big news
attorney general Loretta Lynch
apparently attempted to influence the
acquit investigation while Comey was
there that was a big piece of breaking
news as well and then the piece of news
that the left is jumping on which is the
Comey called Trump a liar several times
in the in the in hearings yesterday and
the final piece of big news is that
Comey reached his memos to prompt the
naming of a special counsel so people on
the right are jumping on this to suggest
this means that Comey is a leaker and at
home he is going to be prosecuted for
leaking we'll talk about all of these
things but here are the key clips from
the from the hearing yesterday did any
individual working for this
administration including the Justice
Department ask you to stop the Russian
investigation no at one point the
Attorney General had directed me not to
call it an investigation but instead to
call it a matter which confused me and
concerned me and although the law
required no reason at all to fire an FBI
director the administration then chose
to defame me and more importantly the
FBI by saying that the organization was
in disarray that it was poorly led that
the work force had lost confidence in
its leader those were lies plain and
simple I asked a friend of mine to share
the content of the memo with
Porter didn't do it myself for a variety
of reasons I asked him to because I
thought that might prompt the
appointment of a special counsel okay so
here were the big headlines and there's
a lot of conflicts over what the
headlines should be I mean just to show
you how much conflict there wasn't what
the headlines should be this is a a
picture of CNN and Fox is covering the
exact same hearing and having precisely
opposite headlines here it is the
conflicting Tyrone's you can see CNN
saying that trumps that only took
Trump's request about dropping the Flint
investigation as a directive and then on
the right you see Fox News saying Comey
the president did not order me to let
the Flynn probe go so it you know again
everyone sort of taking out of this what
they want to hear I'm going to give you
the big headlines as I saw them
yesterday and then we're going to go
through what the reaction to all this
has been so as I said first headline
Comey basically blows out of the water
the Democratic narrative that there was
collusion between Trump and Russia in
this election cycle and that from fired
Co means to cover this up even Chris
Matthews is acknowledging this now
here's Chris Matthews acknowledging as
much but the big story to me has always
been as all this and I think Nicole
really touched on it their key the
assumption of the critics of the
president of his pursuers you might say
is that somewhere along the line in the
last year the president's something to
do with colluding with the Russians
something to do the helping hand
encouraging them feeding their desire to
affect the election in some way some
role they play some conversation he had
with Michael Flynn or Paul Manafort
somewhere and yet what came apart this
morning with that theory because in to
repeal regards the president said
according to the written testimony of
mr. Comey go ahead and get him anybody
satellite to my operation and nail them
I'm with you on that so that would be
man-mana Ford Carter page someone else
like that and then he also came across
they what was fascinating Comey said
that basically Flynn wasn't central to
the rushed investigation that he was
touching on it that there was of course
Flint had an honest that we assumed
wasn't honest in his answering of their
official forms the audit ought to become
become that Security head but they've
only touched on that did it wasn't
really related to that but he could be
flipped for that but in other words they
could flip them because they had them
caught on something he dishonestly
answered but he wasn't central it seemed
to the Russian thing and I will
assume what Trump was afraid of he had
said something to Flynn and Flynn could
be flipped on that and he Flynn would
testify against the president that he
had had some conversation with Flynn in
terms of dealing with the Russians
affirmatively
and if that's not the case where's the
there there if it is different to me
what what Mathis is saying right there
what masters saying right there is the
key and that's the thing that Trump
should be seizing on because that's
amongst the entire leftist narrative and
when even Chris man awake he does know
that show Gator morning Gators have put
comma capitulate without fell apart you
went even Chris Matthews gets it that
demonstrates that the Democratic
narrative fell apart that was headline
number one headline number two was that
Loretta Lynch pressure James Comey to
change the way they were terming the
investigation into Hillary Clinton
calling it instead of an investigation
calling it a matter
okay now that had already been revealed
by the New York Times way back in April
people really didn't pay attention to it
at the time Comey said it now so now
it's in the testimony and people on the
right are jumping on that yes
that's terrible and yes Comey should
have done something about it he should
have gone public with it or he should
have written a memo to file as he is so
fond of doing and all of that is true it
is also true to be fair that if we are
going to say that we are disturbed by
Loretta Lynch putting pressure on James
Comey and how he did so it discusses the
Hillary investigation then we should be
similarly concerned if President Trump
is putting pressure on Comey in any way
with regards to any other investigation
like let's be a little bit consistent
here in all of this okay third headline
president Trump apparently acted
improperly and call me pounded troubling
so we can't get away from and this is
what the left is jumping on they've now
pivoted from their original narrative to
the new narrative which is that Trump is
a bully and a thug because Trump said to
Comey pull them aside in a meeting told
everybody else to get out of the room
and then told them he hoped that Comey
could find a way to let Flynn go now
people on the right are sort of ignoring
this or pretending it doesn't exist or
saying well it's not obstruction no
one's saying it has to be technical
obstruction as Alan Dershowitz has said
Trump could overtly tell James Comey
that he wanted him to drop the
investigation and that he would go and
he's ordering him to do so and that
wouldn't necessarily constitute
obstruction of justice
on a criminal level but impeachment is
not a criminal offense impeachment is
about what is politically palatable to
do
Democrats could jump on this and they
are the biggest problem for Trump is
that now because you said all this stuff
now you could end up with the situation
where Trump actually is under
investigation so we found out that Trump
is not under investigation right we
found out that he wasn't under
investigation
when Comey was the head of the FBI and
that Comey told him that several times
and that's probably why Trump fired him
is because Comey wouldn't say it
publicly but now because of the
conversations that he had with Comey
he may very well be under federal
investigation from Bob Mueller these
special investigators that means that
Comey if he wanted to nail Trump has
played his cards exactly rightly which
means that Comey is kind of sui's but it
also means that Comey has outplayed
Trump here right here's how the chain of
events went basically Comey was called
into Trump's office and Trump said to
him I appreciated you to get rid of this
Flynn thing right I hope that you get
rid of this one they never want to put
it and then Comey didn't pay attention
to Trump continued on his merry wife
didn't see anything so wrong he had to
report it and then he gets fired and
then Trump tweets that there must be
conversations between Trump and Comey
that are on tape and call me better hope
they're earned at which point Comey
responds by revealing the presence of
the memos which prompts the creation of
the special investigator and now that
special investigator is going to look
into Trump over obstruction so in other
words Trump did two things that now have
put him on the hook where he wouldn't
have been on the floor one he had
conversations with Colombia Bob Flynn
that he shouldn't add and two he then
tweeted about how he had tapes which
which prompted supposedly Comey to
reveal the memos in which the memos out
which prompted the appointment of the
special prosecutor now some people on
the right are saying well that means we
should get rid of the special prosecutor
a little bit late for that okay guys
regardless of whether you think that
Comey did the wrong thing in revealing
the contents of the memos in order to in
order to debunk what Trump was saying
about him the cats out of the bag you
shut down the special prosecutor right
now it looks like Trump really does have
something to I so Trump's in a catch-22
because now the special prosecutor
according to combing will probably end
up looking at Trump's activity toward
Comey and may come up with some sort of
obstruction charge or at least the
implication of obstruction giving
Democrats something to hang their head
on in other words the quote-unquote
cover-up of a crime that didn't
her may snag trump because Trump has a
big mouth that's what Democrats are
hoping anyway that's what that's what
Democrats are hoping now I want to talk
about how Trump can get out of this and
what Trump actually should be saying
about all of this because I think that
he has a pretty good case to make if you
were just honest about it but he's not
making that case unfortunate we'll talk
about it in one second first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
the u.s. concealed-carry Association so
every day you see stories about somebody
break into somebody's house somebody
breaking to somebody store robberies
carjackings riot there's been an uptick
in the last couple of years in murder in
major cities all over the United States
and you want to sleep a little bit
better at night because you know that
you have to defend yourself there's
going to be somebody standing next to
you then you need to go over to the UFC
CAF defend my family calm defend my
family calm and sign up with UFC CA with
us CCA does is it give a responsible gun
owners like you and like me complete
peace of mind that give you training and
how to use your weapon but they also
provide you the defense resources
necessary in case you do use your weapon
I live in California that means if I
shoot a bad guy coming on to my onto my
property then there is at least a
significant chance that I will be
prosecuted or I'll end up in legal peril
u.s. CCA
helps you out with that us CCA make sure
you're legally and financially protected
for effort you pull the trigger and they
help get more guns into the hands of
responsible Americans right now in honor
of July 4th they're doing the great
American giveaway they want my listeners
to know about it if you win right now
you'll receive a 1776 dollar 1776
dollars for the guns and ammo of your
choice like 1776 you get one thousand
seven hundred seventy six dollars for
the guns and ammo of your choice and
they are picking five winners you can
register right now at defend my family
calm defend my family calm to get your
five big chances to win the offer does
not last forever this is design for July
4 so go over to defend my family comm
number one you should be signing up
anyway and number two you can register
to win one of the five $776 prizes just
by signing up so super cool stuff defend
my family calm you seca to a wonderful
work on behalf of gun owners across the
United States okay so with all the
headlines that came out about Comey
and with the new found
temp I the left to push the notion that
Trump obstructed justice
even though as Chris Matthew says there
is no real there there there's something
that Trump could do right what Trump
should do here's what Trump should do I
basically wrote this out yesterday if I
work from here is what I would say I
would say this I did not collude with
Russia during the 2016 election I said
that a long paper and Comet confirmed
there is no evidence to suggest
collusion by me get even admitted
finally that I was not under personal
investigation he told me privately
you wouldn't say publicly that made me
very very angry that is the real reason
I fired him out of anger anger that I
was not being exonerated in public view
even though Comey knew I was not under
investigation also I did not obstruct
any investigation Comey admit I never
tried to obstruct the Russia
investigation he admit I said he should
check out my associate on Russia as far
as my comments on general plan it was
just a nightlife general Flynn it wasn't
measles trying to cover anything up they
were hot state and hot-headed statements
about what I hoped would have a I hope
is hope in order and I had to give an
order I'm done a freaking Crump we have
no evidence that Flynn even did anything
right Flynn lied about talking with
Russian is that a crime isn't it maybe
but it's not a big enough crime to
really care about that's why I said
something to James Comey why is this
even a big deal Comey knows I didn't
obstruct the Flint investigation
he didn't even quit didn't even report
it look I should have patience I should
have had patience with the president but
I'm not a patient guy I want to get
stuff done the clouds hanging over my
administration thanks to the Democrats
is crippling my ability to get something
done don't call it obstruction it isn't
it's nasty there's no underlying crime I
didn't obstruct when there's no crime so
let's get back to work I'll stop being a
patient and you guys stop saying stupid
stuff right that's what trunk should say
that's what from should say and if Trump
actually said that then he might be able
to make a good defense what he should
not do is get into a credibility fight
with James called me he should not get
into the business of trying to say to
James
homie is lying about him and that James
Comey is not telling the truth about
what he said about what the reason being
Comey just testified before Congress
under oath under penalty of perjury who
is more credible now I know that a lot
of Trump camps and he's more credible
than call me okay now Comey
is a lawyer Comey knows that he doesn't
want to get caught up in a perjury
charge and he knows that right now the
entire Trump administration would be
happy to charge him with perjury so the
idea that he's going to go out there and
outright lie is just silly like commis
not stupid okay he may not be your cup
of tea but he's not a stupid man and
primp wants to pick his perception of
honesty against Kobe's perception of
honesty that's not a battle from can win
what Tom should have done is playing a
little bit of jujitsu here Trump should
have said what Trump should have said is
everything Comey said is true as to
content but not is demeaning right
that's what he should have said and I'm
an impatient guy I met with them because
I was upset about the flood and stuff I
didn't mean you should quash them does
it look that I even have a follow-up did
I even tried to quash the Flint
investigation hardly accused me of
obstruction when I didn't do anything
other than saying damn that I hoped he
would see his way clear to letting Flynn
go maybe was sort of a ham-handed thing
for me to say but obstruction really and
again even Comey confirmed that there's
this front brush of stuff it's a big
nothing burger right bad that's what
Trump should be doing unfortunately
that's not what Trump is doing so Trump
came out on Twitter today when Trump
immediately decided to attack homies
credibility which is just not smart
because again he's relying on commis
credibility in order for him to get out
of the Trump Russia stuff right he wants
to say that Comey is credible when he
says that Trump was not under
investigation there's no evidence of
collusion but he wants to say he's not
credible when it comes to what Trump
said to call me in the privacy of the
Oval Office or at Trump Tower so Trump
tweets quote James Comey better hope
there are no tapes of our conversations
before I starts leaking to the press
that's what he originally tweeted that
got him in trouble now here's what he
tweeted quote despite so many false
statements and lies total and complete
vindication and Wow Comey is a leaker
okay I'm the beleaguered thing quick
note people who are trying to say that
Comey should be prosecuted for leaking
his notes were not government documents
hey if I have a personal diary that I am
taking and it's not classified and this
apparently was not classified material
and Trump did not exert a certain
state of privilege from a legal from a
lawyer's perspective this is not
prosecutable okay we're Comey did you
may not like the leak you may think it
makes him a politically motivated actor
I certainly do but I think that to say
that he's a weaker and therefore he did
something illegal he didn't actually
join any legal any more than Trump did
something illegal by talking to the
Russians about Israeli Intel he has the
capacity to do it it may be bad but it's
not necessarily illegal again this is
just bad strategy I'm not saying that
Trump again did anything deeply wrong
here
in fact I'm trying to figure out a good
way to defend Trump but this is not the
smartest way to do this you know in
conclusion with that he sends out mark
castle as his lawyer to make the case
that Trump was that nikomia is lying
about Trump this is not a smart tactic
it's again Trump fighting back and he's
fighting back aggressively rather than
in intelligent fashion here's Mark
Castle it's his lawyer saying Nick
omegle I are not drunk the president
never suggested that mr. Comey quote let
Flynn go close quote okay so with him
saying that is really not smart because
again unless he has tapes to prove that
and he said he has and now the White
House won't say whether there are tapes
or whether there aren't tapes the tapes
will be subpoenaed Trump a monkey goes
under oath is going to leave this
particular credibility battle the best
move would be to do what I just said
admit basically that everything that
Comey said is true and then say commis
misconstruing everything because Comey
is a politically motivated actor I'm a
hothead I say things out of turn but
that's not what I meant is no
obstruction here there's no underlying
crime that's what terms should be saying
instead he's not and that's leading
Democrats to be put in a position where
they can actually do him some damage I'm
gonna talk about that in just a second
but for that I'm going to have to go
over to Daley wire.com go ahead and
subscribe it daily we're calm right now
$8 a month gets you access to the rest
of the show live we part of the mailbag
which we are now doing on Fridays
because hey we're five days a week now
which is super exciting plus if you want
in the annual subscription at Dan Lee
Weyer then if you spend if you get that
annual subscription you get a free
signed copy of this very book the one
that I hope here in my hand say it so
it's a book by me and my dad there we
are yes my dad's my best friend were
actually to have mine next week to talk
about the book actually which will be a
lot of fun because my dad's awesome my
dad is the really nice version of me
which is to say
and I mean really really nice I'm not
super nice my dad is like the nicest
person anyone knows we're heading to
have mine next week to talk about the
book say it so you get a free signed
copy when you go over to daily wire.com
right now and get me annual subscription
or if you just want to listen later go
over to iTunes or SoundCloud we must
review we always appreciate it make sure
that it's 5 stars because otherwise we
won't appreciate it so go over to iTunes
or SoundCloud right now and do that we
are the largest conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]